nos sites d'enfouissement sont pleins on
prévoit en ouvrir d'autres et selon le
rapport du bape les objectifs actuels du
gouvernement en matière de réduction des
déchets sont carrément inatteignable ce
soit le ministère de l'environnement où
la commission denquête nous avait donc
même résultat ce sera un objectif
ambitieux il ne pourrait pas
chaque québécois produits 524 kg de
matières résiduelles par année et le
gouvernement souhaitaient abaisser ce
seuil à 525 kg d'ici 2023 comme ça
semble impossible
le bac propose de changement radical
d'approché consommer moins consommer
mieux et réduire les déchets à la source
nous pensons que la société québécoise
est prête à consacrer les énergies
nécessaires y compris financières pour
l'amélioration de la gestion des
matières cette nouvelle philosophie est
bien reçue par les environnementalistes
ce que le bape nous propose ces deux
peut-être arrêter de travailler sur des
nouvelles technologies de nouvelles
façons de faire au niveau de la gestion
des déchets est plutôt commencer à
penser à comment les réduire à la source
comment éviter un problème plutôt que de
trouver des solutions un problème le
volumineux rapport de plus de 600 pages
évoque de nombreuses pistes de solutions
produits durables et réparables économie
circulaire taxes etc ou frais et
redevances etc les commissaires
proposent de plusieurs mesures des
coffee fiscalité d'augmenter les coûts
d'enfouissement aussi pour s'assurer que
l'élimination coûte plus cher que les
autres alternatives donc vraiment ce
sont des solutions très concrètes
recyc québec au gouvernement au sujet de
revoir en profondeur le mandat de
l'organisme recyc-québec et surtout de
prévoir des mesures plus coercitives
pour des contrevenants c'est pas avec
des gestes individuels qu'on va réussir
à changer les choses c'est avec des
contraintes réglementaires législatives
et c'est le ministère que le pouvoir
d'adopter ces modifications à ces
changements en termes de gestion des
matières résiduelles
la performance du québec est un recul
constant par rapport aux objectifs qui
s'est fixée en 2015 ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal